it's so wonderful to see the last time i
saw you was in new york when you were
announcing your courage tour and here we
are
announcing the show in vegas and vegas
seems to have a really special place in
your heart where your kids were growing
up you're twins and
so many connections to your family so
how did the kids react
when you said mom is doing a show in
vegas again
well it's home for them i've been here
for 20 years
they're 10. i mean my big one is 20.
but yes we've been here almost 20 years
and
time flies that's for sure well i have
to say that
happy kids happy mom happy mom happy
kids they're happy obviously because
i can have the best of we all can have
the best of both worlds i can be a mom
i can be with them every night i can
perform for my fans every night and come
home
so it's the best of both worlds i can't
wait
you are a fashion icon so i can't wait
to see what you said you wear on stage
but
this is like a new beginning listening
to what you're saying i mean
how would you describe this next chapter
in your life
uh i think we all grew so much from that
um
health crisis um we're still
we still live it because we're still in
it uh hopefully something positive will
come out of this
we have to remain positive we still have
to pray and hope
um it makes us grow the maturity and
every one of us
uh is growing rapidly um
it's it's this all that will reflect
hopefully in a positive
positive way so right now this
creativity of mine for this
new show and for the songs and how can i
sing those
old classics of mine and and not making
them look like
old of course not but but
it's such a privilege that all those
years
all those amazing songs were offered to
me and the fans got me where i am today
and i'm i'm almost pretty sure that
these are the songs that they want to
hear
how can i present those old songs in a
new way
so it's a challenge it's a challenge we
have to put
the bar very high every time we work on
a show
and we present ourselves we want to give
the best of
who we are at that moment and that
moment on november november 5th
will be it will be a different me
because there will be different of them
as well
so it's something that i'm looking
forward to
present to as well to perform and to see
the fans again
because all of us have been through so
much um
it will be a new world a new way
it's gonna be it's gonna be very very
strong
i know i know it will be positive we'll
be fine
we'll be fine yes we will
be safe stay safe thank you